I've been told I'm not as treky I'm not
a real Star Trek fan because I keep
complaining about the Star Trek musical
Subspace Rap City welcome to sidere your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel this will be a short lanty video
because I have been quite a aggressively
accused in a couple of comments um of
being not a real trekky not a real Star
Trek fan damn it because I don't like
the Subspace Rap City Star Trek musical
they did in season 2 strange new worlds
episode
9 I'm going to explain again why I
didn't like it for one I don't like
musicals right if a musical is going to
be good and I'm going to enjoy it then
the songs have got to be good they've
got him catchy other than nurse chapel
song about halfway through I didn't
think any of the songs were any good I
thought they were um them saying what
they would have said anyway but to music
and not always that well um nurse chapel
song though I I do agree it's actually
just a bloody good song I actually
really really like that so I didn't like
much of the music it was just it was
just okay it was there it was in the
background but it didn't sort of have me
singing along or anything like that so I
didn't like it from that point of view
and if a musical it needs to get me
tapping my toes all right Chitty Chitty
Bang Bang that's a
musical Char the Chocolate Factory
that's a musical songs are great so yeah
there's that for two and this is a
biggie you only get 10 episodes of
strange new
worlds two of them were very quirky
episodes
right you've got the crossover episode
which was brilliant with lower deck but
a very quirky episode and then you've
got the musical how whether you like the
musical or not you have to admit it's a
quirky
episode that is 20% of the Star Trek I
want sci-fi I want Star Trek I don't
mind the odd quirky episode but
20% of the series in this case workwork
episodes for me that's just too much one
one episode would have been fine one or
the other that is my main argument with
strange new worlds
so before I let it go though I do have
one major problem with the musical it
didn't make any bloody sense and it's
not science fiction that's my biggest
problem they did a
very loose sort of explanation of why
they were all singing musicals um there
was a Subspace whatever fold and a
reality From Another Universe was
bleeding in and blah blah blah it
doesn't make any sense though all right
it's a very loose
scientific dodgy at the end of the day
though that reality would have had to
have affected us in a way things like it
would have had to make us all psychic
because everybody knew the lyrics
everybody knew the dance moves they were
all jumping around to the same and
smooth so they must have been
telepathically linked so that's that's
one that wasn't mentioned and and for
two it's bollocks it doesn't make any
sense it's not scientific remotely
accurate and look science fiction should
be fiction it should be imaginative it
should you know be fictional but science
is in the too and the word science is in
there and if you're going to have
something as Extreme as that h you
better have a better reason for it if
they' have had some sort of psychic
alien that was affecting the crew that
would have made a little bit more sense
or at least I could have followed the
logic there was no logic to Strange New
World season 2 episode 9 sub space rap
cidy it made no bloody sense at all
so those are my reasons for not liking
Subspace rapity it is not because I'm
not a trekky I love Star Trek I just
want Star Trek to be star St Trek not
necessarily a musical I don't mind the
quirky episodes I actually love them but
I want more Star Trek and when you're
only giving us 10 episodes of something
that real estate is
valuable I want it to be science fiction
a science Star Trek one
episode that defies explanation gets a
bit quirky and his comedy and you know
gets a bit silly or whatever that is
fine but not too and the on Dancing bit
it wasn't funny it was just stupid I'm
sorry but it just
was and this is the last time I will
ever mention Subspace rapidy in a video
probably probably not if I'm honest guys
get into the comments as well though and
tell me what you think about Subspace
raps city are you a lover are you a
hater or actually do you agree with me
that if this episode had been a special
instead of the ninth episode which
really should have been building up to
the finale if it had been like a
Christmas special or something would
have been okay but just not to episodes
in one series do you agree with me get
to the comments and tell
me if you are new to the channel don't
forget to like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it helps us out you'll
never miss any of our videos also you
can go to s.co which is our dedicated
website also you can go to patreon.com
for/ Sidra where most of our videos
Premiere
first
[Music]